TO SEND MESSAGES ABOUT WHERE YOU
WANT TO BE NEXT YEAR
NOW NICOLAS IN TROUBLE WITH ONE
OF THE PUCK POSSESSION
SHATTENKIRK.
THAT WAS INTENDED FOR SIMON. ON.
BUT IT'S T
GOT IT COVERED AT TH
SHARKS HAVE PICKED UP SOME
POINTS AGAINST THE DUCKS BUT NOT
A W.
MEIER FORAS.
HE GOES UPSTAIRS AND SHOT IT TOR
NOW MAYHEW
DRYSDA
THE SHOT RIGHT FROM THE MIDDLE
COMES IN, GETS REDIRECTED.
THAT WAS AT NAILED BN FRONT.
IT WAS BLOCKED
ANOTHER ONE OUT TO VLASIC.
TURNS AWAY FROM GRANT.
KARLSSON TRYING TO SHAKE OFF THE
DEFENDERN JUST
LOST IT.N GETZLAF
IS A STANLEY CUPTO
MEIER.
HE SCORES! OUT TO TIMO
AND WHEN TIMO MEIER IS FEELING
IT THA
MARKER THEN YOU CAN SHOOT FOR
AND JUST KEEP
REEDY.
WHO BY THE WAY, CONGRATULATIONS
SCOTT REEDY, PICKED UP HIS
FOR MOST OF THE YEAR
OTHERS LIKE CHMELEVSKI TO  WHER
>> Bret: AND HE DOESN'T STOP
THE SHARKS ANAHEIM'S POWER P
GADJOVICH, CHMELEVSKI. GREAT
PLAY DEFENSIVELY SET UP THAT
LITTLE FAR SIDE. MEIER
MEIER HAS A
AND WHEN HE LEANS INTO IT, BOY,
THIS IS A TERRIFIC SHOA BACKINGN
AS WE'RE FIVE MINUTES IN
>> Bret: TIMO MEIER END OF THE
SHIFT D HE SCORES!
IT'S A HAT TRICK FOR TIMKHAND TE
HAT TRICK FOR TIMO MEIER ASSIST.
BRENT BURNS WITH HIS
TEAM-LEADING 36th ASSIST